[Music]
hello my friend stay a while and listen
what you're about to see will be a bit
of an odd video for me I've actually
believe it or not been working on this
for years I've gone back into gaming
follow me on Twitch in the last couple
of years specifically but back when I
barely played anything besides
Hearthstone and Marvel Puzzle Quest
which is also something I might end up
doing a video on that'll be weird too
but I wanted to lay out my love for the
Diablo franchise
I'd put together a rough script a while
back and was actually starting to replay
the early games to both capture footage
and test them against my own memory now
I did have a note in there almost from
the beginning about my reservations
about the developer and publisher
Activision Blizzard you know between
predatory monetization practices the
firing 100's employees the same year the
company posted record profits etc etc
but I I was still moving forward
I'd finish several of my replays of the
first game and was almost done with my
first full replay of uh Diablo 2 when
2021 happened uh the full scope of abuse
within the company became evident and
well I just stopped working on this
I didn't have it in me to praise even
the old stuff that was associated with
the company but some time has passed
since then and while my opinions have
not changed
I still haven't returned to Hearthstone
and I will not play Diablo 4 despite the
love of the series that I'm about to
profess
I also felt annoyed that I was never
going to talk about what I used to love
about these games so uh
screw it
I used to deeply love these games and I
want to talk about why
in my younger years I did not PC game
very much I was raised on Nintendo and
the ambiguity of having to make sure
that my PC had the specs to run any
given game made me wary of PC gaming
just as a general concept I didn't like
the idea that I couldn't just plug in
any game but there were a few that I did
still get pulled into here's a magic 2
Dungeon Keeper Wizardry eight when I got
to college but the big one was the
Diablo franchise
long before blizzard ruined the
franchise's reputation with the
abysmally predatory Diablo Immortal
which as a quick reminder launched with
a progression system that required
either a hundred and ten thousand
dollars of investment or 10 years of
play time to fully boost a single
character no I'm not kidding
and now they're trying to claw that
reputation back with Diablo 4. but the
first three games ate a significant
number of hours of my life and I should
mention at this point this is not going
to be a comprehensive look of either the
history or the mechanics of the Diablo
franchise this is going to be me
relaying my own personal experience with
the games and talking about the bits
that I think are neat and how those
evolved over the first three games I'm
not a game designer most folks would
probably consider me a borderline Casual
Gamer at the best of times and just to
make the point one final time do not
take this video or anything I'm saying
in relation to these games as praise for
the company that owns and produces the
franchise I will say it at least one
more time Activision Blizzard
so uh with that out of the way let's
actually have some fun I probably thank
my enjoyment of Warcraft 2 for getting
me into Diablo in the first place if I'm
remembering correctly the expansion disc
beyond the dark portal which I never did
beat all the way through included a demo
for the then upcoming first Diablo game
you remember demos when actual finished
sections of gameplay were just given
away for free to show you how good this
finished product you could buy was going
to be instead of things like closed
betas where you have to basically win
the lottery for the privilege of playing
an unfinished game
yeah I'm old anyways it was effectively
the first segment of the game up through
the battle with the butcher around the
third level down into the church
I was hooked pretty much immediately
as mentioned I was not the most plugged
in gamer even at the time so I can't
really give you much of an assessment of
how big a splash the game made on the
gaming scene as a whole I mean I know
it's sold well but finding out more
specifics would be
a research thing and as that's not me
I'm here to have a nice stroll down
memory lane today if it's all the same
to you so speaking only for myself
the first Diablo was something of a
revelation
I'd gotten into RPGs on the Super
Nintendo but those were nearly all
turn-based colorful and absolutely
nothing like this this was dark action
focused highly replayable thanks to the
randomized elements I would actually
argue that the first game is the most
replayable game of the series with the
random factors in the way that they are
implemented which is quite intelligently
in later games uh there were a lot more
fixed areas and the quest progression
went the same on every playthrough
really all that was randomized by the
time we got to Diablo 3 was the loot and
the shape of most of the dungeons so
overall the follow-ups felt more linear
and rigid with each entry with the only
major variance being the kind of
character you build to get through it
all which is not necessarily a bad thing
but we'll get to all that in the
original game you wouldn't always get
the same quests each time they'd come at
you in clusters so for instance in the
first few floors of the church there is
a cluster of Two and a cluster of three
so you'd either get the poisoned well or
the Skeleton King and then you'd get two
out of three from a cluster that
consisted of the butcher Ogden sign and
garbad the week odds were you'd get at
least a slightly different mix each
playthrough with the random elements
still being controlled enough that you
know you were almost guaranteed to see
all the quests at some point if you
played through one time with each of the
three character types like I say it's
well balanced for the size of that first
game three character classes pretty much
ensures that you'll see all the content
if you go through with each one if there
have been more character classes that
would have exceeded the variation
granted on the replays if there'd been a
fourth class to play through you'd have
nothing new to discover in terms of the
quests Randomness in general is much
much more baked into that first game and
it ran through a ton of its elements
affecting almost everything from
encounters to quests to loot naturally
to level progression since that first
game the randomness has been dialed back
with each new entry to the point of
becoming
honestly a little bit token keeping the
loot somewhat randomized makes sense as
ultimately Diablo is a loot heavy series
and maybe even the dungeon Interiors to
at least keep you from memorizing the
layouts but
I don't know why are the open areas of
the second and third games laid out
randomly so you're stuck walking the
Outer Perimeter with the mini map up the
whole time just to figure out what the
heck is even there I mean in Diablo 3
most of the really significant areas
have fixed layouts rather than random
ones which just serves to highlight how
unnecessary and vestigial the entire
idea of the randomness has become at
this point it just feels like it's there
because of tradition
I suspect the only reason they don't
pack it in altogether with the
procedural Maps is fear of fan backlash
but it would honestly make more sense as
a design element at this point to just
drop it well they may have in the fourth
game I don't know I won't play it but by
the third game even it would have made
more sense to get rid of it but coming
back to that first game in the
randomness
there was an interesting Wrinkle in that
the three playable classes weren't all
that rigidly defined I mean granted they
did play differently they had certain
things each was better at than the
others the Rogue moved faster in general
and could fire arrows more quickly than
anyone else could the Warriors swung
faster with melee weapons and plus had
the strength to wear the heaviest armor
and carry the most damaging melee
weapons and the Sorcerer had the biggest
Mana pool and did the most damage with
spells there were also stat caps for
each class that would keep you from
boosting a sorcerer's strength stat so
high that he could wear scale mail or
boosting the Warriors intelligence to
the point of being able to cast big
high-end room clearing spells but until
the latter parts of the game where you
got to the high end gear and the high
end spells that needed the truly top
tier stats there was nothing stopping
you from equipping a sorcerer with a bow
or having your Warrior cast spells as
long as you met the stat requirement
in that first Game Gear wasn't class
specific just stat restricted that very
first time I started with a warrior
because he was the easiest to get a hang
of but the Rogue was my first completed
playthrough I loved her long Raiden
specialty and while she couldn't rival
the sorcerer for spell damage
she could get her magic stat high enough
to cast some pretty decent spells the
sorcerer was by far the most challenging
because in that first game learning
spells required finding spell books
which were random drops
like all the other loot you could also
buy spell books in town from the witch
but that was a really expensive and also
got randomly reshuffled each time you
came back to town in other words it was
theoretically possible to be trying for
a sorcerer run and just never come
across the books for the Spells you
really wanted
or more realistically not finding as
many as you want because that's how you
level up the Spells is by finding more
books of the same spell so if you had a
favorite spell there was no guarantee
you'd get it at an opportune point in
the game and also no guarantee that you
would be able to level it up to stay
effective as you went deeper and deeper
into the dungeon
this did sometimes make the sorcerer a
pain to play but let me tell you
if you did get the good stuff
you felt like a walking nuclear strike
and it was pretty awesome now honestly
the atmosphere of the game was the thing
that really blew me away at the time
The Moody music the dark Graphics the
sense that something was about to jump
out from around the corner at any moment
oh my gosh whoa befall any adventurer
who went through a doorway into a room
full of gargoyles without realizing it
or there were also those things called
The Hidden which were flat out invisible
until they popped into existence to
attack you the story well the story is
honestly pretty basic but if you're like
me and replayed this over and over and
over again to see how much better you
could get your character on this run
then
you spend so much time just in the
environment you get immersed in the
world without needing a particularly
deep narrative to do it
now each of those first three games in
the series has always had multiplayer
and I'll admit I didn't really bother
with it all that much especially not in
that first game I mean
I was on dial-up internet in rural
Vermont for crying out loud so the first
one was for me at least strictly a
single player experience but
it was one I kept coming back to over
and over again
each time somehow feeling new even
though I've been through the whole thing
multiple times I would still take the
time to talk to Farnam or come up with
snarky comebacks for a warts BS
and yes I would indeed stay a while and
listen the first game takes place in
nothing but a single Town built over a
seemingly bottomless pit of baddies
every five floors or so there's a shift
in scenery as you go from relatively
well maintained rooms to aging Stone
passageways
caves and eventually the very depths of
hell
the sound design and the music were
especially good at drawing me in Diablo
as a series but that first game in
particular has one of the all-time great
unsettling ambient soundtracks there's
groans that you'll hear and you can't be
sure if it's part of the musical score
or if a zombie is about to eat the back
of your head
[Music]
there are times you hear a babies cry
off in the distance and that's part of
the actual music
and I don't know how composer Matt
Yeoman managed to make something as
familiar as an electric guitar sounds so
otherworldly in some of those deeper
areas but it sends a shutter up my spine
to this day
[Music]
The Voice work
well it's good for the time
High man most part of me and I'll get to
work a blizzard had access to decent
voice actors uh then they'd really knock
it out of the park when it came to
Warcraft 2 but that also had a lighter
tone
[Music]
Diablo's more serious feel meant the
slightly exaggerated voices of some of
the characters
they don't fully gel please no hurt no
kill keep alive and next time good bring
to you but nothing so off that it breaks
the spell that the game casts over me as
a player well besides some of the
sorcerers pompous line readings it is
hot down here I suspect you may have
noticed that I have talked about the
atmosphere the feel quite a bit uh not
so much about the plot because
there really wasn't much of one and what
is there can be ignored if the player
doesn't feel like figuring out the why
behind all this there are details you
can't help but pick up monsters coming
out of whole goal down hole kill
monsters that's enough motivation for
most players and if you feel like
skipping through dialogue you don't have
to engage with a story at all really but
if you want to
there's plenty going on with character
backstories and World buildings
sprinkled across the game for whoever's
here for that glory and approbation to
Diablo Lord Of Terror and leader of the
three it's one of those games where a
ton of work and planning went into the
setting
and very little went into the plot and
for other games that might sound like a
criticism but the original Diablo it
seemed to be aware of the fact
nobody was really here for the plot
it's kind of like if you've ever played
Doom 2016 you remember how that
approached its story if you wanted the
story it's around you can pick up on it
if you feel like it but you're here to
kill monsters in space and doom and in
Diablo in a dark fantasy setting and to
get better gear for doing so so
it's worth saying that while there isn't
much of a narrative there is a ton of
lore if you really want to dig into that
end of things I tended to be happy with
the bits I picked up over the course of
the game and honestly letting my
imagination fill in the rest not being
that much of a lore Hound myself though
despite not being all that big into lore
I did rather enjoy the monsters and boy
what a lineup That was there were
skeletons zombies skeletons with bows
and arrows gargoyles demons some of
which I will probably have to censor or
not show you at all and then later when
someone's gave us cat people and
porcupines big bugs bats okay uh you
know what it's not exactly the most
original creature lineup in the world if
I'm being completely honest I suspect
they were largely selected for being the
best fit for the atmosphere and just
being darker versions of
fairly standard fantasy stuff with the
more Whimsical things such as fairies or
unicorns or honestly even dragons just
being thrown out and not used but for
the darker side of fantasy it's guys are
pretty well covered I mean we've got
things like the Fallen ones which are
basically Goblin equivalents and they
speak in this jabbering language and
they get resurrected by uh
a shaman
okay that that feel that feels a little
off
I did it's an accident I'm sure I mean
that that kind of Monster's been around
since the very first one the sort of
traditional uh later on the second one
the jungle area there's the uh uh the F
the fetishes
[Music]
oh oh dear
okay so maybe we best move on from the
monster Concepts at this point uh and I
mean given the isometric view is not
exactly a show piece for the graphics or
the creatures anyway now uh I never
played the expansion Hellfire but it's
just as well it was a third party
project would later be declared
non-canon anyway so when I was in
college
there was Diablo 2.
I don't know how many hours of sleep I
lost to this one and its expansion the
base game had five classes with unique
skill trees and abilities and select
gear that only their class could use so
you couldn't really multi-class like you
could before but it meant that even
within each class were significantly
different play Styles because each class
had three disciplines to gain new
abilities in and craft a precise play
style for how you wanted to approach
things this meant that even within a
class you could craft a different build
on each playthrough in the initial game
three of the five classes were analogous
to the ones from the original the
Paladin played similar to The Warrior
the Amazon played similar to the Rogue
or at least she did a few specialized in
bows and the Sorceress was naturally
similar to the sorcerer for the newbies
we had the Barbarian which was a
Powerhouse with a less controlled style
than the Paladin wading in and just
berserking his way through enemies and
then there was The Necromancer whose
skill set was best for creating his own
personal Army of Undead minions to slow
down the enemy hordes while he stayed
back and picked off whoever his forces
couldn't take down on their own and then
blew up the corpses because that that
was always fun there were a ton of new
features ad as well such as armor sets
where each Unique Piece becomes more
powerful the more matching parts of that
set you have class specific equipment
the ability to supplement your equipment
with gems and runes even higher an MPC
support character who you can also equip
with better gear Diablo 2 also built out
the world significantly partly for the
obvious reason that it's not taking
place in a single town there were four
acts each with a new setting with a
different fundamental feel and new
baddies to take on you start out in a
rogue encampment and the First Act is
honestly very similar to the original
game on pretty much every level from the
monsters you encounter to the general
aesthetic and the music the soundscape
of it to the fact that it ends with you
descending into a cathedral but then you
move on to the desert where you're
dealing with a much more lively City
brightly lit environments a shift in
musical tone in more wide open areas
then you've got the jungle for act three
and that yeah no we're not going to talk
about them and you finish up in hell for
act four none of these are super
original settings on their own I mean
it's basically grassland deserts jungle
and lava levels from Mario with a dark
fantasy makeover but it gave you a much
better picture of the larger world the
first game really only hinted at
there's also a lot more plot going on
though you as the player kind of have an
odd role in it so the backstory of the
first game was that there are three
primevals of which Diablo is only one
and they're trapped in things called
Soul stones on the Earthly plane and
they can still exert influence Diablo's
Soul Stone was damaged so it's not
enough on its own to contain him now the
first game ended with the player
character shoving the Soul Stone into
their own head in an attempt to keep the
demon at Bay within themselves now
canonically it's the warrior who does
this but there is also a rogue and a
sorcerer who were present and there as
far as the Canon is concerned the second
game firmly cements the running threat
of the game series being the corrupting
power of evil and all three of the first
games Heroes were tainted by their fight
with Diablo the Rogue and sorcerer
appear as boss fights in the first and
second acts of Diablo 2 respectively and
the warrior is now referred to as the
dark Wanderer so he's going through the
world working towards freeing Mephisto
and bail the other two prime evils and
horrible things basically follow him
wherever he goes what you as the player
are doing is following the dark
Wanderers Trail and trying to undo
what's been done to the areas where The
Wanderer has been so basically
you're the janitor
and if some folks don't like this and
feel like it's annoying to not ever feel
like the main character I don't really
have a counter argument to that but
speaking personally
I really dug this
I've said many times I love the idea of
playing out smaller stories in a bigger
world so
I kind of like that you're playing as
someone who is unlikely to be remembered
when all this is over
the things you do matter but you You're
Nobody you're not a figure of Legend
You're the poor schmuck who has to deal
with what happens when figures of
Legends drapes through and wreck
everything
the Diablo 2 expansion the Lord Of
Destruction added on a Fifth Act which
may be my single favorite setting in any
of the you're up in the snowing North
where the barbarians live and you start
at a fort and it's under siege so the
first thing you do is guard the gates
into a literal Army of enemies you'd run
into hordes in the games before this but
having them assembled for a purpose
rather than just being something you
stumble across really gave this a whole
new feel the expansion also brought the
usual new loot and such but it brought
not one but two new character classes
the Assassin who can be built to get in
close and take enemies apart with
martial arts a bit of a glass Cannon
kind of build or set deadly traps for
the enemies to set off
or both and the Druid who had some magic
some summoning stuff a little similar to
The Necromancer and also the ability to
actually transform to either a werewolf
or a Werebear and completely change the
nature of combat by basically becoming
either a speed demon or a power tank on
the Fly
story wise the expansion also pretty
well wrapped up the narrative by the end
of Lord of Destruction all three of the
primevals plus two out of four of the
Lesser evils have been defeated
though it does end with the destruction
of the world Stone which is said will
alter the course of the world going
forward and that might sound like a
sequel hook but where is the original
game and the Diablo 2 base game both
left things with flagrantly unfinished
stories this is a point where you could
actually stop and feel like
it's just an uncertain future which is
an ending style that usually works for
me
that's probably part of why blizzard got
away with taking more than a decade to
release Diablo 3. now Diablo 3
took me a little time to warm up too if
I'm gonna be totally honest I did like
it it brought back all those warm
dungeon crawly feelings but most of the
settings felt like visually upgrading
versions of old ones none of it felt as
new as what Diablo 2 added and some of
the changes and new features they took
me a little bit of time to come around
on
one of those was the original way that
the loop drops were handled so you may
not be aware of this but these were
originally clearly designed to
facilitate the real money economy and
auction house where players would pay
real cash money to bid on gear they
wanted so to encourage trading and sales
those initial loot drops were pretty
much completely random and the odds of
you getting a bit of gear for your
specific class much less one you wanted
weren't great this was rightfully
derided by critics and fans alike and in
less than a year from launch it was
confirmed that this would be removed
from the game and I never went in for
this thing but once the auction house
was gone the loot drops were rebalanced
excellently so you primarily got stuff
for the class you were playing and I
found the progression of gear and the
Rarity to be really well handled
once the Malarkey with the auction house
was gone so that initial problem became
all kinds of moot but uh it would have
been a pretty big Omission for me to not
mention it especially since it was an
early indicator of the kind of bull that
Activision Blizzard would start pulling
him in later years in regardless of
monetization but anyway ways Diablo 3
came with five character classes two
holdovers three new ones the Barbarian
firm Diablo 2 was just ported straight
in and the Sorceress was rebranded as a
wizard well it was effectively the same
class
for newcomers there was the monk which
played a little bit like a melee focused
assassin there was the Demon Hunter
which was like a mashup of a trap
assassin and a bow Amazon and the witch
doctor which brought together elements
of The Necromancer and the Druid this
was the first game in the series to not
have genders pre-assigned to each class
in the first game The Warrior and
sorcerer were always male and the Rogue
was always a woman
Diablo 2 with expansion had barbarians
necromancers paladins and Druids for sir
and sorceresses Amazons and assassins
for the ladies
Diablo 3 allowed any class to be played
by any gender which sounds like a minor
touch but was something I actually
appreciated quite a bit for what should
be fairly obvious reasons especially
this was around the time I was really
starting to question my own sense of
gender
this sort of tweak kind of describes
actually many of the improvements the
franchise made over the year small
changes that you might not have thought
to ask for
but they were great once he had them
gelbow is actually one of those Series
where it can be pretty hard to go back
and play the earlier entries if you
don't have Nostalgia goggles to put on
because you're suddenly missing a ton of
tweaks to the play the progression
quality of life improvements that were
added later on that it's just hard to
imagine the game without for instance
after you play Diablo 2 and get to plan
your character builds and how you intend
to spend your skill points it is kind of
hard to go back to Diablo 1 and be at
the mercy of the random number generator
in order to be able to acquire Spells at
all but speaking person at least I
probably wouldn't have complained about
that element of Diablo 1 at the time
only after I got to play the refined
alternative
which brings us to the main aspect of
Diablo 3 that took a bit of time for me
to warm to and that's the new skill
system and the leveling well actually
there's also the visuals it doesn't feel
as Moody to me this time it's really
hard for me to pinpoint why that is so I
didn't want to dwell on it probably
something to do with the Lighting
systems uh but anyway the way Diablo 2's
level progression worked was that once
you spent a skill point
it was gone it's part of what prompted
me to replay Diablo 2 as many times as I
did realizing that I could have
allocated my skill points better than I
did and going back all the way to the
start to do it properly or just wanting
to try out a completely different build
for kicks and back when I was in college
and had the stamina of a 20 something I
really dug that
with Diablo 3
you can actually reallocate your skills
at any time new tiers of skill open up
as you go and you can take points away
from one skill and drop them into
another or even change what ones you're
using at any point well I'd sort of not
quite at any point uh when it was
initially released it was an always
online game so you couldn't pause and
switch things up make combat and even
now
um you aren't allowed to change it while
you are engaged with enemies so there
has to at least to be a lull in the
combat but if you're feeling
experimental you can get out of the area
you're in and rework your build the
ranged combat Demon Hunter not quite
working switch it around try melee
focused variety
initially this actually annoyed me for
what I now recognize as a pretty
immature and stupidly gatekeepy reason
because at first I thought it made
things too easy
I thought about how many hours I had to
sink into Diablo 2 to make my best
characters and that I had to do it each
time I even had a new idea for a build
but now any old putts can just switch
over to a completely different character
build without earning it what
yeah yeah for a few months I uh I was
that guy
I just still think I was a guy at the
time so it's okay to put it that way I
am proud of it thankfully I did keep
those thoughts to myself I didn't post
them anywhere they were still there
though but I came to love that aspect
even at the time because I was 30 when
Diablo 3 came out I was working a job I
had a kid and I frankly did not have the
time to restart the game every single
time I wanted to do a new build I still
don't have the time to do that even now
that whatever this thing is you're
watching is actually my job and I work
from home
I don't have to start over anymore
yeah I've realized I've become the gamer
who needs the easier way to do things
and my ability to do that doesn't
actually affect the experience of my 20
year old cell who was prepared to play
until 2AM which bless them I'm not this
is also the game which the player
character has the most agency within the
story instead of playing just another
human you're now a Nephilim basically
the descendant of demons and angels
without truly being either so you're
more significant this time your actions
actually drive the plot there's still
plenty going on beyond your scope but
you're regarded as more of a threat by
the forces of Hell than you ever were in
the first two games
and that's another thing that took me a
little bit of time to get used to but
by this point it also makes sense to
escalate the player's importance the
story also ties up the loose ends of the
two remaining lesser evils who had yet
to be seen actually in the games up to
that point so it tackled asmadan and
Belial there's also some aspects of the
plot
I just I frankly don't love
like there's a rather Grim fate for a
character I'd gotten quite invested in
which just felt
cosmically unfair
then again it's certainly in keeping
with the tone of the series so I can't
say it's a bad fit or anything like that
just that it was the kind of grim that
rubbed me the wrong way for some reason
I I don't know it's just like a step too
far
another thing about Diablo 3 is this the
point where the story at least seemed to
be running out of steam Diablo 2 had it
easy because all it had to do was expand
the world beyond the one town but there
isn't actually all that much which the
third one was able to add World wise as
I noted most locations are heavily
reminiscent of previous ones really with
only the High Heavens being anything
truly new as for the plot the final two
lesser Evils are dealt with Diablo
himself manages to come back again
spoiler alert get another Smackdown
which
honestly feels a bit tacked on which
might also be part of the reason I don't
like the fate of that character because
it's tied to that anyway like his return
in the second game felt inevitable with
the way the first one ended but this
time it feels way more like the story
contorting itself to fit him in because
his name is literally the name of the
game it's not a total face plant but
after this there wasn't really anywhere
for the thing to go at this point that
wouldn't feel like a retread of some
form and one could argue the story was
already starting to feel that way after
Lord of Destruction
that doesn't mean that uh blizzard
stopped of course enter the Reaper of
Souls expansion which does indeed feel
like a rather needless addition at least
as far as the story aspect is concerned
all the evils of Hell have been dealt
with so now we have a corrupted Angel
instead which is functionally not all
that much different it's still a decent
expansion it added in the Crusader class
uh which plays a bit like the Paladin
from the second game but
it can't help but feel anemic especially
when compared to Lord Of Destruction it
felt like little more than an after
dinner mint
there's also a rise of the Necromancer
DLC but all that did was bring in the
Necromancer class it didn't expand the
story or the world in any way so I
actually didn't even bother with that
one
now there's more to the series than just
the games there's novels Comics some
characters appeared in Blizzard's Heroes
of the Storm back when that was still
trying to be a thing
I never really got into those with the
current state of Activision Blizzard
it's a guarantee I will not be trying
out any of the newer games anytime soon
probably not at all Diablo Immortal is
just insulting and while Diablo 4 is
getting strong reviews at the time of
this recording it's not enough to get me
to support the company as it currently
exists and no I'm not gonna shame or wag
a finger at anyone who is deciding to
play it or any other activist product if
you're playing it enjoying it that's
great for me I just I I can't that's a
me thing making that decision a little
bit easier though is that some of the
details about the release have come for
it it really makes Diablo 4 look like a
retread more than anything else it
launched with five character classes and
not a single one of them is new we've
got the Barbarian sorcerer Druid Rogan
Necromancer one or two Legacy classes is
one thing clearly The Necromancer was
popular enough to justify an entire DLC
in Diablo 3s but not even a single New
Concept
really
I don't know
it's clearly not scaring people off the
game it made a shockingly appropriate
amount of money pulling in
666 million dollars in its five-day
launch window and good for them I guess
but I'd rather boot up the older gains
and relive those experiences
yes I am old thank you for noticing but
the Grim reality is I don't have much
hope
for the future of this franchise at
least
not for what I used to love about it
but I will always have those first three
games
and for me
it was one hell of a ride
are you a fan of Diablo
what do you think about it do you like
for the reasons I do do you like it for
other reasons are you playing and
enjoying Diablo 4 whatever your thoughts
may be I'd love to hear them drop them
down in the comments let's talk about it
patreon pays the bills enables me to do
this as my living there's links to other
things they do in the description don't
worry all that much about it though
because what I really want you to
remember
is you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
Nama thanks my patreon supporters that
make this possible including Robin Moore
Zubin lipfula to rock the thing that
goes doing in the anime Ruth Oliver B
solitary pictures
Ulrich bogdon Linda Walters Jan t love
Auntie kate808 bernabe likes the poodle
Robin Powell Tracy scrabot angry Casper
Adam RDL Taylor Dave Hall Shayla gourlay
and Rosalind Bennett
you can get uh my the bat I get all the
names right and then I can't talk if you
want to hear me stumble over my tongue
after saying your name it's in the
rewards here on the patreon
[Music]
mmm